all right Fox News has this report
real-time host Bill Maher confronted
former Democratic New York Governor
Andrew Cuomo on the nursing home Scandal
that plagued his handling of coid while
sexual harassment allegations led to qu
moting from office in August 2021 there
was a lingering controversy over his
ill- fated policy in March 20120
ordering nursing homes to accept coid
patients in order to prevent
overwhelming New York's hospital system
that led to the deaths of over 4,100
nursing home residents during Friday's
overtime segment on YouTube M read a
viewer question uh post to Cuomo asking
whether he would have done anything
differently during Co and Cuomo
responded the short answer is no first
this is Monday morning quarterbacking by
which I could make the New York Jets
champion if we're going to do this when
Co started it was all of the dis all the
disinformation was amazing it's coming
from China uh wet Market okay so he's
saying there was disinformation was
coming from China and they didn't know
any better um and so they did what they
could with the information they had
available that's basically his answer
now along these same lines we also heard
in the same episode from NYU Professor
Scott Galloway who was a big proponent
of mandates and lockdowns and all the
rest of it and U here's what he had to
say about uh the response from people
like him to co watch well I was on the
board of my kids school during coid I
wanted a harsher lockdown policy and in
retrospect I was wrong the the damage to
kids of keeping them out of school
longer was greater than the risk but
here's the bottom line
myself our great people the CDC I'd like
to thank the governor we were all
operating with imperfect information and
we were doing our best so it's
it's so let's but let's learn from it
let's learn from it let's learn from it
let's hold each other accountable but
let's bring a little bit of Grace and
forgiveness and that show the
West okay so we hear again about the
need for great Grace and forgiveness and
uh as always this calling for grace and
forgiveness coming from people who uh
would never extend it the other way to
their own ideological opponents and
never
do um and this particular guy I don't
know anything about him
um but very often with these people you
know if if they say that they should get
Grace and forgiveness for doing things
or or for calling for actions that I
mean that killed
people right in the case of in the case
of Cuomo the case of Cuomo killed
directly killed thousands of elderly
people and um the people that were
pushing for lockdowns for so long I mean
that killed people
too
and isolating taking kids and isolating
them in this way the damage that was
done to those children is it it's
literally immeasurable you can't measure
it you can't quantify
it um because it it it they were damaged
at such a deep
level and so for that they want Grace
and forgiveness but a lot of these
people if you were to ask them you know
what about um what kind of Grace and
forgiveness would you give to someone
for I don't know quote unquote
misgendering a transperson for that
destroy their lives get them fire
destroy their
lives but hey if you're a governor and
you did something that killed thousands
of elderly people hey it's it's uh they
they were doing their best he tried
that's all that
counts all
right a couple things about this in
general first of
all if this was May of 2020 okay if we
were in May of 2020 right now or or June
of 2020 and someone who advocated for
lockdowns initially a few months
beforehand that would mean was coming
out and changing their mind
in May or June or July of 2020 or
something like that a few months later
then in that case I would say sure okay
look you got it wrong at first uh there
was a lot we didn't know initially you
were scared whatever okay but it's not
May of 2020 it is the last day of
October of 2023 and that's significant
because a lot of these people who are
asking for forgiveness and Grace now
coid amnesty or whatever whatever you
want to call a lot of these people maybe
all of them were still advocating for
lockdowns and mandates in June of 2020 I
mean they were pushing for it in June of
2021 okay so the time frame is important
here these people were pushing this for
a year a year and a half two years even
longer you know I remember I went to
that Davidson County school board
meeting in
um that would have been August
of
2021 uh to speak out against their mask
mandate and I was accused of being a
homicidal uh you know coid loving
Maniac at the
time all those many months
later so that's where I stand on this no
one is saying that everyone had to have
everything figure out from the very
first moment I mean nobody did when if
when it it first happened and Co first
made it here to the United States nobody
knew everything about it immediately and
no one is saying that you had to know
everything about it
immediately but these people were
not just pushing this tyranny in the
first moment they were pushing it in the
first moment and then in every other
moment after that for years not just
weeks or months but for
years and it it it they weren't just put
pushing it they were shouting down and
trying to actively
silence the people who were
right and who the Scott galloways of the
world now admit were right except they
don't really admit it do
they like they're saying the things that
we were saying before but he's not
saying oh those other people were right
because that's that's maybe the most
important detail in all this since the
overturning of roie Wade the left has
lost their minds leftism is their
religion and portion is their official
Sacrament meanwhile pro-life efforts
which are now more important than ever
are booming despite the narrative Pro
lifers have not gone away in fact
they're getting more and more active is
one of the largest prif organizations in
the world no one's in a better position
than 40 Days for life to end abortions
state by state they've opened a record
number of location since row was
overturned and they continue to grow in
volunteers they now have 1 million
Volunteers in 1500 cities 40 Days for
life holds peaceful vigils outside
abortion facilities in an effort to
change hearts and Minds in the most blue
pro-abortion States you can help 40 Days
for life fight ongoing legal battles to
protect free speech for their volunteers
by giving a tax deductible gift of any
amount at 40 days forlife.com that's 40
days forlife.com
before I could ever even
consider forgiving one of these people
or what before I could ever consider
giving a vote for amnesty for
somethingone like this and I still
wouldn't but before I could even
consider
it what I would need to hear from them
is not oh I didn't know
I didn't know I was ignorant I didn't
know no I don't want to hear you didn't
know I want to hear you didn't
listen because that's what actually Happ
you didn't
listen Okay when it comes to he was
talking about shutting down schools from
the very beginning there were many
people who were saying don't do this you
can't do this here's why you can't do it
and giving uh very intelligent reasons
one of the reasons is that
co uh was was not especially dangerous
for children and that is one of the
things we knew about coid basically from
the beginning there are other things we
didn't know from the beginning we one
thing one of the facts that we knew from
the beginning and that and that you know
was a fact that was established almost
immediately and remained a fact the
entire time is that this was not
especially dangerous for kids that the
flu is more dangerous for kids than Co
we knew that right
away Scott Galloway says he didn't know
how did well what you didn't know how
did you not know when everyone else
did now we knew like we as in the
Universal we this was a known fact that
was out there in the world it was a
knowable
fact but you didn't listen to the people
who were trying to tell you not only did
you not listen but you went out of your
way to shut them
down
and um so that's what I would need to
hear first but I I don't think we've
heard that yet have we we've heard for
the calls for forgiveness and Grace but
the people that are calling for this
they never say Hey listen I didn't
listen to you guys I should have
listened okay I should have been more
humble I didn't listen to in fact not
only did I not listen but I I I tried to
shut you down I tried to get you
deplatformed and I was wrong for doing
that and I'm sorry and I'm not going to
make that mistake again and uh in the
future when when the other side is
telling me things that that that that
that I don't want to hear I will at
least listen to them and let them
speak I don't think we've heard that
from a single one of these people have
we we haven't heard anything even close
to
that instead all we hear is well nobody
knew no one could have known nobody
could have known these things that
millions of people were actually saying
from the
start so this is a you you know you
can't can't really
have even if we wanted to talk about
forgiveness even if we were interested
in forgiveness you can't actually have
forgiveness without any without
accountability uh it's because what are
we forgiving exactly you haven't
actually repented of
anything and there's not any
accountability they're not holding this
was accountable so so they they're
they're pretending that they are but
they actually
aren't and the reason why someone like
this is never going to come out and say
hey
uh I should have known but I didn't
listen to you guys he's not going to say
that because then he knows that going
forward on any other topic he's not
going to be able to call for for us all
to be silenced on some other issue
because he'll already have admitted that
you know there are times when
instinctively he disagrees with what
we're saying but then he turns out to be
wrong he doesn't want to admit
that um and so
you know they can take their am their Co
amnesty and shove it as far as I'm
concerned hey YouTube thanks for
listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there